me and the dog were laying in bed
getting ready to get up and i heard
what sounded like a round a full round
of gunshots
and um i knew it was not fireworks this
time because we have a lot of those
going off
came outside cops were coming down
we had barricade situation i heard them
on the blowhorn telling them to come out
and yeah it was definitely gunshots this
time we blow off a lot of fireworks
we are gun owners
so for you can tell the difference
between a gunshot and a firework we've
had
a hostage situation back about four
years ago on thanksgiving it was a
fugitive
we had the fbi here it was closed off
about a year ago we had an airbnb we had
some kids partying
gunshots went off in the garage swat
came
they got all the kids so we have a lot
of airbnbs in this neighborhood
we're trying to get rid of them and this
is why it's the airbnb parties before
the airbnb's came into our neighborhood
it was
we had a lot of teenage kids and we also
had a gang that lived in the apartments
across
durango the m13 gang so they were
wandering our neighborhood back then but
for the most part
it's it's very quiet i mean for 20 years
i gotta say it's a really good
neighborhood i've had we've had
situations i've had two runners
running from the cops through my yard
through my neighbor's yard
so that happened once that was scary
because they actually came
close to the home
but other than that i'm not really too
worried we're we're pretty safe here
for what i got going so and i got a pit
bull
so i'm good the blow horns with them
telling people to come out
with their hands up it was not a pretty
sight this morning
this is not a bad neighborhood don't
don't get the wrong impression it's just
this happens everywhere it's just we
have a lot of airbnbs in here
i think that's the cause of it